[Music]
[Applause]
hello happy Monday I'm Eric joined by
Alessandro today we're gonna play uh we
got we have early look at a kind of fun
upcoming action RPG game called shadows
awakening I know you've seen it like
once or twice at different kind of like
press trips now and I've gotten my hands
on it for like I don't know three four
hours but yeah I want you to tell me
more a little bit more about your
experience with the game and you know
just your general thoughts I guess
before we hop in here yeah shadows
awakening for those who don't know or is
a part of the sort of a heretic kingdoms
series the first game came out in the
late 90s and it was called cult heretic
kingdoms and basically it's a sort of
isometric action RPG in the vein of
Diablo so you fight monsters you collect
loot you level up you know
yeah we'll show you some of those
systems here in a second because we're
gonna start a new game basically hence
why the stream is called the first 90
minutes yep I do like the some of the
subtle touches that we'll see here in a
second once you hop in strip and then
I'll discuss more of that because you're
controlling multiple characters at some
point but and and you will kind of
almost right off the bat so what are you
gonna do you're gonna go old-school
you're gonna be normal let's just do we
want to see as much as we can exactly
and you can play keyboard mouse or
controller awesome user controller is
gonna play on controller because that's
how he played it before this is the PC
version yes we're playing on PC but
it'll be on other platforms as well I
guess for his for so yeah if you're
looking in for an action RPG game maybe
similar to like he said Yahoo style
maybe path of Exile this this could be
right up your alley
I like what you'll see it here in a
second which is like you do have to kind
of get through some of the world some of
the puzzles through some of the
mechanics or the systems in the game
yeah there's a lot of really clever
puzzle solving I guess the main hook for
this game in particular is that you
control multiple characters here and let
this breathe and should feel we know
one just guilted on I yeah but I've had
bit of time for students it was once an
honor to be entombed within these
ancient catacombs but centuries have
passed at now only the brave or
foolhardy walked these tunnels
perhaps I'm the last living soul here
although I'm far from alone this is not
my story although I am the architect of
what transpires a conspirator in the
ruination that threatens the heretic
kingdoms and the most unlikely of
alliances that might yet save us all
sound so ominous
he's like a deckard King yeah except he
doesn't unidentified stuff for you not
Deckard Cain definitely not all right
here we are
so this is how we start off so uh this
is the main character nose let him talk
first and I would betray you
without hesitation if I deemed it
necessary but we are fortunate you and I
we have the same enemies our only hope
lies in partnership which is precisely
why I have summoned you here demon
so as Alessandra mentioned this is
pretty much your primary character as
you see in the bottom left corner you
have like multiple character slots of
which unfortunately three are unlocked
but we're gonna get one of those
unlocked here in a second and the cool
thing as you mentioned yeah I'll turn I
turned up sound a bit it's delayed so
you guys probably won't hear it till now
but and as mentioned once we get that
other you know character playable
character here in a second you'll see
what we can kind of do what Alessandro
is able to do basically swapping worlds
essentially or different perspectives
right and as mentioned in some cases
that you know even those rats that you
see right now we can't see them moving
because they're kind of like in an
alternate world essentially right but
here we go this is where we will make
our first big decision
not sure if it's gonna be is it just ps4
and PC I want to make sure I don't tell
you guys the wrong info PC ps4 and Xbox
one so those are the platforms it's
gonna be on yeah just so you guys know
no word on switch at this yeah someone
asked for a switch port so who knows but
for sure those those three and I'll try
to get the questions as much as possible
but in this case so there's three
different characters you can find out
some background story and also just find
out what type of character is a warrior
so it goes in pretty much teams it's
pretty straightforward because these
three you're gonna see here in a second
he's almost like a barbarian I picked I
picked this character I'm guessing the
story also changes a little bit suits if
you pick someone else care if you wish
and I wouldn't be shocked if you get to
get one of these characters later and
you miss them because there are avenues
as to which you can swap your team
around so here's the next character of
jasker he's like your hunter Archer
Ranger from the whatever did you pick
first was it the third the caster yeah
their sorcerer I wanted to see as much
of you know sort of magic usually mages
are pretty powerful early on shoes
Jessica
twenty eight
I think Amazon I saw PlayStation four
one was but a September fourth on
PlayStation is what it says 2018 though
so like q3q so as mentioned this this
would be your caster your sorceress fire
chat chat what do you want the warrior
barbarian the kind of like rogue hunter
Archer or the sorceress caster will let
you guys pick I know it's gonna take a
second because of course as mentioned
there's a little bit of delay with chat
but we'll see well whatever comes up the
most in the next I don't know minute or
two water that'll be what we pick I can
say that this is actually a sequel to
the shadows heretic kingdoms which came
out a few years ago did you play that
game I did not actually I sort of missed
out on it I was aware of it but it was a
busy year in 2014 so but yeah I mean
this game is very much in the vein of
that like where you play as multiple
characters and new you sort of level
each of them up as you acquire them so
nice slick said his August 31st force
team that's cool
you got one daughter fire one sorceress
us to sorcerer's you have warrior
there's another one that says take her
so that's three sorcerers for sorceress
everyone's picking made sorceress do it
alright that was close enough or fast
enough rather there's only like one
Archer hunter sorry alright I took what
came up first and that was a lot it was
an overwhelming sorceress caster so
now we have I thought that was the
cheesiest line yet he must be Shang
Tsung yeah can you hear me
daughter of fire I can do you remember
the reliquary crusade do you recall how
you died
lady Mara Taran and the others we were
raiding my mother's vault in order to
defeat our I do not remember what
happened
Taran betrayed you but I never learned
what transpired this mystery is yours to
solve I'm afraid do not speak as if I am
not really like the vanity climb no
there are several storytelling mechanics
like each character has their own
dialogue and like you have certain
choices they can make but for the most
part there's more than these yeah
there's the actual gameplay our fates
are bound together demon either we shall
find a way to survive together or we
shall both surely perish there how
threatens me
no something far more dangerous than AI
threatens us all join me in the Tholian
Arcanum as soon as you can we have much
to discuss
it's it's got Diablo like the gameplay
mechanic part of me is like Diablo
with some you know some of their own
stuff going on but then you know as all
asan dimension there's some storytelling
that might be well no not might be is
deeper than Diablo yeah which is is
interesting I'm curious to see what the
story looks like for her in the city
because as mentioned I played as the
warrior who was like former king of that
city so we'll see how this goes
and now we're getting to the character
switching mechanic hip which is uh so as
mentioned there's the rat it's moving
around now in this world you have to
solve potential puzzles or do certain
things as one character versus the other
because you can't get through some stuff
like I think the demon can actually get
through that wall without your help here
and then there's a treasure chest there
very much kill these rats though hey
don't I never killed the rats here your
boy look the rats will come out really
cool about that yeah so like if you are
webbed right you could actually demon
walk away and then switch back and then
you done web so there's fun things like
that
ooh nice kind of upgrade already hmm
once well we'll keep going before I
actually have you go into the menus
because I feel like we'll show off some
of the stats and inventory and things
like that so there's traditional stats
kind of old-school Diablo style where
you can put in strength you know
endurance health points things like that
and then also there's like kind of like
a talent tree essentially that you can
like as you see alessandro right now
currently has one skill unlocked but you
can unlock more skills as you level up
and you get some choices there options
of like what you would like that to be
so traditional looter here you know you
want to check your services for all that
silver
yeah and then I think it just like
swapped back so yeah I know there's
monsters here there's like that bridge
that you couldn't Ross I think sometimes
there's chests so if you end up
experiencing this or playing this as
well I would make sure to like swap back
and forth a lot because there are like
chests that you may miss being in one
form or one realm or versus the other
show puzzles uh probably aren't too many
puzzles yet because we're at the very
beginning of the game but we'll get
there in a bit you'll see something
within this first 90 minutes all right
possi and there was a test for the demon
they're essentially basically yeah well
show equipment in a second well cuz
there's a bunch of stuff you can equip
them let's look at this yeah right here
so I'm already good on four dollar fire
so let's look at what he's got so
basically got a lot of more gearing to
do and some of it seems tons of looting
on this game basically and then if you
are triggered yep so here I think now
all the time - I could pick one point
one skill point for both the devourer or
the demon and now the daughter fire so
what would you like your second spell to
be yes that's some in the sand golem it
seems good good to have another Oh yep
there we go hailed it good to have
something to draw aggro and stuff like
that yeah you're gonna I guess you're
gonna do that for both okay sounds good
oh you can go back in there real quick I
think and do stats so here you got
strength you got agility endurance
willpower no and it's in the old school
like a sort of Dungeons & Dragons where
you can actually upgrade each particular
area the attribute your for your class
yep and it's in the game tells you who
it's like which stats are mainly for
what but I mean like it'll still help
you you know it's always nice as all
Chandra did there to be kind of balanced
and yeah I'm sure I didn't see fresh I
haven't checked the gear itself but
maybe you know do you know if any other
gear
like gated by stats because like that's
a very Diablo thing to do right like you
can't wear this unless you have enough
strength but I don't know I don't know I
saw that things just level yeah it's
just lovely
so far so not necessarily gated now fly
um or you put your so you can upgrade
gear by adding essence to it yep which
is like gems which will get soon
hopefully to as well alright so as we
saw the player only yes single-player
only no online co-op unfortunately as we
saw earlier this bridge is a broken so
we can do is I guess I mean in theory
this is a mini puzzle so here's your
puzzle here's the puzzle a puzzle a
puzzle yeah those are basically how you
get like health back right yep you can
see the icon it's in between the health
and the mana you will read at the bottom
you know I hope you ever get low you can
pop one of those stones and then you'll
get like now that skeleton Archer is
basically an animal realm sanctuary you
get healing here but then this would
also technically if you had the other
character playable characters you could
potentially swap here so and there's a
lot of characters you can find in this
game Thank You sorcerer what are you
doing well technically you go in the old
games you would have to have strength to
wear stuff but you know
it's fine it's it's okay to buff the up
the other is that sometime yeah you
don't want to be a class can't so it
looks like you might have to swap your
attention that I think that will burn or
find a different area that's good and
upgrade and upgrade for your demon can't
go through here Oh rats oh boy that's
what they want you to think they want
you to think like no I'm just throwing
around I know for the fact that you know
they eventually like some elite rats
gonna like crawl out of the walls or
something they'll be like um I'm gonna
mess you up man like you know you
thought we we thought we we couldn't do
anything but when it happens then you
can say I told you so
sure but until then I'm gonna hold you
by also as in the Chinese zodiac ER I'm
a rat so it's it's really tough watching
them die right now okay here's what it
is and and as you can see as you get
more gear now your character will change
[Music]
there we go but the shrink says warrior
attribute yeah but I mean like I said
I'm sure it doesn't affect it too too
much at least to start I mean it's not
like the end of the world if we put two
points of strengthened we can probably
fix that later don't judge me for my
choices and how I build my character
that's what the internet does that's
what that's what they're there for
so you can actually target with the
controller which is good yep all right
you eventually have all the characters
yes
it's interesting though is at least
unless I played it wrong I got through
technically what was the first chapter
and I never got another character which
kind of makes sense because you probably
want to progress through the game a bit
before you know giving people more
characters that they have to know cycle
through or learn so it's probably good
to start off with a few and then well
that's a lot easier than when I was
playing the Barbarian
but the Barbarian had like double the
life so at least there was bad what's up
Cali gaming are you alright alright oh
nice a chest
as mentioned always get back into the
other realm in case there are goodies
like this alright and the good thing
about the is like the game pretty much
automatically well I think equipped the
more upgraded or better pieces of gear
so you don't have to think too much
there but oh here's that's a puzzle
later yeah here's the puzzle yeah that's
one of them is this co-op no there's no
co-op unfortunately it's a single-player
experience is there a level cap a
streams role if there is I didn't get
that bar in it unfortunately and we can
only show so much so maybe slick knows a
little bit more because these things
pretty knowledgeable about the game what
systems is this coming out on Xbox ps4
and PC I think it's like I'd mentioned
August 31st for PC and then I think I
saw September 4th for ps4 's
no co-op is a little sad yes this what
it is but I mean back in the day is I
mean in a way your co-opting with
yourself huh by using a bunch of
characters so you remember I do this oh
I got it okay
you got it now is this a MOBA you
actually could have made that it's a
little free giving yeah but yeah you got
the no really I guess okay I guess
market uh maybe mine was more towards
the center when I did it so there we go
I mean some of this stuff was like kind
of interesting but then I can kind of
get frustrating like I had one where I
had to do a boulder and that one was a
real hell of a time because there's like
doing this with like multiple levers and
if you timed it wrong the boulder would
just fall off well all right we're
almost through the puzzle there she's
good I bet you that corner right there
that was a secret item where the map
just don't yeah at this point so far
there's a little spot to go to but it's
not a big deal it's early in the game
you never really lose anything in the
beginning finally a game that can
compete with four night I don't know
about that but uh sure crime yeah it is
a bit like trying in Diablo I guess it's
a fair way to describe it you have
multiple characters in each with their
own is the spells you got another banana
oh the X mu is really good it stuns them
yeah go get them gone it's the thing
that spider would be weaker to fire
considering fires like literally the
counter to spiders if you've watched
arachnophobia
yeah I know I'm not I
spiders are like one of my top most
hated things oh that's our upgrade - all
right I don't think it equipped though
oh you know what you might not be able
to use it cuz you're the daughter of
fire how much is this uh what's
interesting is when I went to Shadows
awakening at the Calypso shop who is the
publisher by game form you can pre-order
the Steam version right now for $33.99
let me see what the ps4 says it's coming
soon an Xbox on Amazon ps4 was looking
like 49.99 I believe there's a pre-order
sale
yeah it must be that 15% off for $33.99
that spider has six legs these are
basically like wave fly sensor gage he
had already the hooded man's me have
always liked when you're playing like
sort of like these sort of fantasy RPG
games they say like reward that's just
so like old and it takes you yeah it
first again like it's okay you're
talking to the guy that like literally
just plays game for loot and doesn't
really like people I was just spamming
through some conversations because I was
like I gotta talk to every merchant
pretty standard and you know an a RPG
game to make sure you know every
merchant spiders in my house but I
wouldn't exactly call them pets that is
fair some people do have them as pets a
crime has a pet spider well now I know
why we don't get along crime ooh those
are have essences oh there's a little
yeah that little gateway portal there
there you go now you can put those into
your different items as you had
mentioned earlier as they enhance them
essentially they're like gems at least
in my mind they're like gems all right
let's check him out right here at
essence yeah sorry I did not play on
controller so I have +10 crit lifesteal
all right that sounds good bad and you
can abort it yeah 20 yeah and we can
take him out when we need to right I
believe so I never I never actually
tried swapping I guess it was like early
on so how can you use that oh sweet okay
I don't know why I did not oh he quit
hmm that's weird maybe they did so
because uh we're just getting new items
yeah I guess maybe only the new items
just equip then I take that back earlier
what I said yeah oh nice it had seven
attacks beat that's always good well 5%
chance to stun all right great you
haven't leveled yet so oh wait oh yeah
okay you haven't gotten that ability
there's one where you get to you'll see
you later you basically get another like
talent
go away rats here no comment
what country are you in wearing the u.s.
thickest that door right there that
gated door I think she can open it I
just don't forget that shadow crystal
cemetery that we were using I do not go
down that well let's check out I didn't
even know that was a thing you can grab
that book that I think yeah I feel like
this is just like some system chatting
hey hi is this how it no it's not
all right Lucas yeah ring and a soul
stone of met oh so you can change this
whole stone - hmm which is cool but not
yet five casting speed it sounds really
good and yep that happened to me a lot I
was like man but it's good I mean it
makes you go like okay next time I love
all I'll be able to put a bunch of stuff
on so you know alright so we're gonna
throw so I'm curious as to how this
works out because as mentioned I played
the Boyar barbarian who I think was
former king of the city so that story
lines gonna be very different to top an
ancient stone plateau amidst the red
sands of the Outlands lies the city of
Thor centuries ago it was a major
garrison for the guru lien Empire and
they may even have been a settlement
prior to this era these days toll is a
city of thieves and outcasts fugitives
of all kinds come here to avoid
complications in neighboring nations dub
everyone info has a price upon his head
but no one who dwells here is innocent
[Music]
the guild of steel like to call
themselves mercenaries protecting the
few caravans that ply their trail across
the desert yet those that do not pay for
their protection find the guild equally
adept at brigandage
the guild of silk call themselves
merchants and do indeed sell all manner
of goods and trinkets though it is best
not to ask them from whence they came
a vast stone Gates is all that remains
of the Barbican that once defended these
layers now it guards the city of Thole
once more from the Horde of nomads that
precedes it for three years I have been
hiding here amid the detritus of the
heretic kingdoms but it is only a matter
of time before my former allies locate
me and I am running out of places to
hide
we're playing shadows awakening for
those asking this is not Divinity three
tomorrow game reminds me a torchlight
I love that one's a real estate 31st of
August for PC Oh curious what he says
here then you are in charge of Thor I am
Duke dharmic cadastre Intendant of soul
on whose authority do you rule and you
are you may call me a via I am visiting
Seoul incognito to pursue a personal
matter so I would appreciate your
distance not really google incognito
it's not incognito if you tell people
without jewels breaking out under siege
it's a new game coming out there Tom
Brown definitely got some Diablo tribes
Diablo esque protected it from assault
for centuries and the city shall not
fall
my watch welcome to though area this
conversation was way more I guess
Pleasant or I don't know
have you ever play as the barbarian
you'll see basically I'll give you a
quick backstory because so the former
king who was killed by his son basically
comes back to the city and he's like hey
maybe I'm I'm looking to get revenge on
little you know on the boy and then and
that that guy the Duke there he knows
the former king he's like why are you
here I'm not gonna let you just do
whatever you want kind of thing anyways
but we're playing a via so a different
storyline as mentioned so that's one of
the cool things so now you're gonna walk
up there and realize hey I don't have a
key
I need a key of course yeah August 31st
for PC and then sounds like early
September for consoles if you believe
Amazon September 4th the combat system
seems a bit simple and boring well gamer
it's in action RPG games they seem
they're definitely more simple when you
start the game right because you don't
have that many abilities so you're
almost always Auto attacking you know I
think the layers here would just be how
you switch between yourself or you know
your character now and also the the
devourer or the demon and kind of
chaining your skills together as
mentioned you know and when this
character got spiderweb you could
technically switch to the demon to get
out of the spiderweb and then swap back
if you want to so it's about juggling
different characters and you know as you
get farther into the game you'll get you
know more abilities and there's even
like a tree that we haven't even been
able to like dive into yet because we
haven't been able to unlock it I think
there's a quest here later or at least
there was for me but entering a dungeon
or the hostile rather
do some web learning teams because I
don't think this is part of the main
quest I don't think but it's fine yeah
nothing helped me saying go on 36
percent off Green Man gaming is Green
Man gaming legit I mean it's been around
for a while
I've never purchased from Green Man
gaming have you I have no but a lot of
people have but I can't tell you if you
should buy it from there or not but it's
also 15% off on Steam for $34 so there's
that this is so much like derivative in
any original sin I don't it's in the
sense that it's isometrics
yeah but not gameplay now this is more
Diablo yeah definitely meets Diablo
there's stronger storytelling elements
in this game compared to Diablo because
you do have multiple characters and the
dialogue changes a lot more and you will
have opportunities to make choices and
so obviously that dialogue changes too
as well because of like you know this
character and then the demon character
and the and kind of just what happens to
even the demon because he's basically
absorbing these personalities and you
know slowly but surely some of those
tendencies from you know these souls
that he's essentially taking on start to
rub off on him and he even questions for
himself like oh that's not what I was
oh yeah is this the beta version of game
we just have a preview build I don't
know if it you would consider I guess
you can in some ways honestly don't
remember it I think you shouldn't fight
him no because he is not losing life
that one little wonder if he's like so
there was like joke enemies oh wow yeah
oh she's not hurting you wrote bad you
know like those like Goblin enemies I
run away oh yeah but those guys give you
oh so you think I'll you say you thought
maybe treasure goblin yeah that's very
um how many hours would you say you can
get out of this game I'm not really sure
I only beat the I think well there's a
couple layers to that right it depends
on how much are the sidestep you do so
there's a lot there's a good amount of
side missions in each area technically
we were allowed to show up to past this
first city so I'm not really sure how
many more cities there are past this but
is it accidental the crystals with the
swapping yeah because I was like dude
you might need those later depending on
when we get to another fall just depends
I mean the PC we're playing on is kind
of beefy I think it's overkill for this
game but I don't have the actual PC
specs Tom Brown but I wouldn't think
that it's a very demanding game though
so
here it is
there's a lot of cyclists Tom so you
like technically I think I was told that
the first area would be about five hours
but it only took me about three but I
also left behind like a you know a
couple side missions for sure yeah you
might need the mission to get to that
chest right that's okay you you did pick
up a side quest by investigating those
skeleton or tile or whatever so
hmm
all right so I have to find the hood and
hood it man yeah you're not gonna be
able to do that for a little bit all
right
so you might need to go talk around the
city and stuff like that
forgot what air shot is up that way
this way yeah keep going our wall yes
iron like where you can on the map
I believe he's up there does the game
have different classes says Oh nippy yes
so you get to control multiple classes
he's right there that's our shot when
with a merchant's allowed to form guilds
I am able to see your chance to stop us
yeah so we could have picked a barbarian
warrior we could have picked out like
the same class but we chose the shot but
you eventually will see all those
characters to play with cycle through oh
here we go
alright I spam through so many okay no
one in my guild I think I'd be surprised
if the guild of steel have one either
there is a hooded mage who enters there
some oh really goes there how can I help
yeah you do want to get through some of
his stuff though because I think like if
you do him a favor it like it along
he'll tell you where to get a key unless
is a bad time to be Italian legend the
city is surrounded by a horde of nomads
intent on sucking it terrible things
look in the shadows of the catacombs
he's a mean nothing like a seeds to
drive up the price of food huh how long
will the supplies last I have to say
really possibly a year if a sandstorm
forces the nomads to retreat even longer
to mention Khorasan gates Weaver
he may have means to help us beyond even
this it's an inconvenience but there are
big how can I help any tasks I might
take on tyranny you aid in return for
something it would be my honor to have
your assistance in a number of
problematic situations not even just one
you know I've lost a few merchants
they're your favorite fighters nasty
creatures and recently hiding in every
shadow it seems there's also a more
delicate matter one involving shall we
say the reappropriation of assets ask
your questions take care of the spiders
leads to the next thing
I got hopes lady bidding me the Caucasus
of 10 spiders and I'll pay you five
apiece or I should have come here first
search inside no I think it was a spot
next to the hostel wasn't actually at
the hostel so you can we even go do that
question or we can always read those
later
I'm not sure if it has the enhancements
chase it's not Xbox only Xbox ps4 and PC
seem no word on switch though so you
keep going past the hostel you'll see
the somewhere over oh yeah it straight
it then all those little bags on the map
or technically are icons or go kill some
spiders and some rats no there's plenty
of rats in here trust me I know they're
there are but they don't attack you it's
like you're just shooting at them for no
reason we're about efficiency they're
not here for pest control would have
August 31st with PC and then it looks
like early September possibly for
console is that's what it says on the
Amazons no poor spiders remember that
movie sparked starship trooper do the
same thing I actually will just watch
that recently again it doesn't really
hold up but because of my nostalgia for
it I still like it yeah
I saw that movie far too young like so
many of the people that depends it
depends I guess you could argue that
some of it ever since the Lord of the
Rings spiders have been bad
I think fighters have always been bad I
mean outside of the spiders maybe
killing mosquitoes and stuff for me like
I could care less for them personally
gonna break that wall down later to find
me you probably can't we need to hit
level three to so much stuff to be put
on at level three equip the sand amulet
and she crits a lot yeah oh it was just
a skeleton archer with zoo spiders how
big is it download I actually I'm not
sure KP I forgot you guys I'm sorry
there's some of that spider body part
singing nine oh eight more ways to get
also hold up to activate quest I think
it'll just show you how many you have
oh by the way I think it's like one of
your guys died you just both died and if
you didn't save then you're like pretty
f we should do that
because I don't know when the last time
in autosave it might have been when we
swapped will you try different weapons
we did actually we swapped from the air
we're using the air stuff instead of the
fire staff as it's technically better
also because we put in essences in
someone whose weapon so it's probably
not a good time to switch them how many
classes are there well to my knowledge
at least three more but there could be
or well to read there might be four
maybe more than that to be honest for
now there's just the core archetypes of
the mage warrior and the road yeah but
you also played a fifteen-minute build
where I saw like you had one other type
of class which I wasn't sure exactly
which class that was because she had a
sword and shield anything yeah once you
keep going through the game like they'll
definitely open up a lot more
interesting like characters to play as
this is not coming to switch yet that we
know no he only announced platforms or
the ones we mentioned earlier ps4 Xbox
one and PC
I mean I would assume that that would
just be a fact of like how popular this
game is on the normal consoles and
depending on how that goes then that may
or maynot inform their decision on if
they could you know make another version
everything's better on switch though
that's not necessarily true man mmm FPS
games come on so you you think that Doom
is a better on switch I appreciate that
it's on switch you just you just took
your words and spun them in another way
that's not how this works I mean sure I
mean there's you know I mean that's the
one type of genre that I would not want
to play on switch only because it just
doesn't feel like it holds up as well
now that's not to say that somebody
that's never played that shouldn't play
on switch it's just hard for me to go
from playing on console and PCs and then
playing that game on switch because I
just feel like that's not how I would
want to play it sure but like you said
you can appreciate the fact that it
while people don't own like ps4 is and
maybe Xbox ones or a good PC so you know
a switch version might be a solid you
know option for them I also I'm in the
camp that I it it's painful to me that
those are $60 games but oh yeah show
them that tech that I taught you
and then write back and then you could
do it again if you wanted to it doesn't
matter
the okey-doke this dream has an ad for
the new Slender Man movie oh that kind
of sort it well know that what an image
this makes me think spiders but it I
don't think it is Wolfenstein is coming
to switch though yeah I know but that's
another one of those games where I would
tell you if you have the other platforms
that's probably how to play it however
maybe if you've never experienced it you
wouldn't really be able to like
differentiate the two or like be maybe
as like stubborn as I am being about it
not for doing I agree with you err
thanks crying oh no this is a boss guy
have fun all right I think he's a boss
guy our way now is it I can't remember
ah puzzle okay oh I don't remember doing
this one this is gonna be good guys I'll
be here with chat while he figures this
out tom process I agree that rerelease
is of games on the switch should not be
full price yeah oh hey great job what's
this fella for it looks great knows not
the al before although the rumors is
they are making oh wow what is that I
got a purple alright that's pretty good
except you can't wear it
what is it so many level three good see
that that's that's the one part I like
about action RPGs a lot is that they
always make a make you one at like keep
playing because like all the good stuff
oh that's hilarious okay
he reset yeah yeah that would have been
mean to be honest cool that there are
puzzles in this game yeah um if we get
to that Boulder one that wouldn't
annoyed me a bit but it is still a
puzzle so
you know I can't maybe it was personal
frustration like you're pulling multiple
like levers and stopping time kind of
like what you were doing you know
earlier it's you'll see so we need how
many more of those spider bodies you
need if you hit up on the d-pad is it up
on the d-pad nope it's definitely in
your journal you can change the spider
Colts at the gala thing we're going you
can switch it okay that works
yeah we're too low level but it's not
far off that purple which is shocking I
I missed that item the first time I
played so and at least it didn't screw
us over and give us like a class that we
don't use which that only happen just
stick it in like the vault or something
like we had that like blue bow that we
got and I'm like oh we're not gonna use
that for a while all right four more to
go
it's not like that Tom Brown as much as
like the demon is the way that you bring
some of these souls back to then be able
to play as other characters but you can
also play the demon oh you can get that
sick Waypoint right there
oh right and then you get to you know
maybe that one I think we've got to be
at the same trailer which is good yeah
you got to finish the spider quest
anyways you need to heal at all there's
that thing to you next to you then
there's a bunch of spiders if you walk
forward and then get to the end of the
next room
how many classes are there is their
skill tree Oh tabula rasa good ol six
socket Armour in path of Exile yeah we
can show that in a second let's maybe
after we finish the quest because we're
almost there it's not from this side
either
no you get to pick your skills tabula
rasa I think when we hit level three
which will be soon actually you get to
unlock some more stuff too which is
pretty cool that we'll check out rat
killer Oh level three all right this is
a good time I guess the game itself is
telling us to do it so there's these
skills oh let's put this thing on that's
that's a good call let's good shout that
did not add a visual effect but that's
okay yeah alright once you do your
skills and stuff now that you're so
talents that's something like another
layer now that we've hit three you can
choose from a bunch of stuff so crit 20%
damage to set things resist there's a
bunch of stuff
durability endurance buy ten more coins
more so basically more stats or base
stats so and then what was the last one
yeah based on your character
intelligence it was good one right yep
where is it out there I think it was at
the beginning
crit and like damage and resist and I
feel like intelligence I think stats are
better than some of that stuff to start
okay so that's that and then you can do
it for your demon as well more bag space
I think I did I think I cheat a cheese
dit by using or sort of cheese day with
regen cuz I was like losing life but
that was just me those we can do a bunch
of stuff yeah it doesn't matter what you
can do endurance which i think is his
main style what's interesting is that
from what I gathered from this is like
you know he has a lot of stats that
focus on or perks they focus on like
sort of the overall like a sort of
character ability like increasing
inventory and you know they were a
general helper generation and stuff so
yeah and also getting more silver so you
can do whatever you want as well as your
oyster alright this is going to be on
switch unfortunately not to start so now
you can do attributes so here is I'm
just gonna put everything in strength
how about that and you want the chat to
get mad again alright um I think I think
endurance is life
so that's more hitpoints and then you
know obviously this is helpful for mages
as well in just in case things get you
know too close for them let's put one
then let's just dump everything in here
all right
there we go alright so now you got to
make good choices
is it demon alright and I think you have
a new skill you can potentially learn as
well so this is some of the menu stuff
that you guys were looking into and so I
think that one yeah now you can level
either curse of the desert or fire
shield I don't have enough points for
this one yeah or as you mentioned if you
have enough skill points then you can
upgrade to where yeah let's get a third
option here fire shield - yeah alright
all right all oh then she kind of got
some necro skills to be honest got a
golem hmm actually unlock this way I
never said it okay
shadow wave hmm more damage let's try
this I guess it does it for you and your
they call them puppets yep alright the
talent stuff I don't know if you can
change the skill stuff you can change on
the fly so if you like one skill for a
certain boss or something like that you
can change it
I think the stats are pretty locked into
from from the stuff I've seen so far
we're still looking for some spider body
this is not made by Larry name this is
everybody Jim just need one more so okay
there's definitely some up that way but
you just gotta be careful there's a
bunch of archers in here
and there's also fireballs that get shot
all right and it gets pretty painful all
right at least a August 31st for PC and
then I believe it's early September for
one more spider get that quest done and
then war do some more nice all right
used everything I like it Skelton soon
no chance
oh you get scorpions - I didn't realize
it was a curse and a summon
she's almost plays more like a necro
she's like a summer almost okay these
guys down
keeper hard for me to tell you in my
limited experience I think there's some
interesting things going on at somebody
that does play Diablo but I didn't get
into the nitty-gritty enough to really
give you a strong judgment in terms of
like
oh wow he's already good all right
ah all right good I was gonna say watch
your help with the game at least for the
first time earn it kind enough to tell
you themselves just don't get hit by the
fireballs they heard a lot okay
oh you're against night
that's kind of cheap the shooting from
down below upwards but now that we'll
open that gate I think the doorway is
hella Ross ass and our skill points are
earned per level only or can you get
them by other means I haven't seen skill
points and things like that through
other means but again I only beat the
first chapter so sorry but so far it
seems pretty traditional where you just
get points as you level how many classes
are there there's at least three not
counting the demon and I feel like
there's a fourth that you might have
played that I don't know what that class
is called there's again the character
classes where there's multiple
characters in each of those classes you
have the players so you there's a bunch
of different characters to find and they
all play differently this is definitely
not a review Tom just so you know it's
just a preview if anything
give you guys a taste of what it looks
like and some of the systems still need
a spider body I don't think there's too
many spiders in this area so I would
just be careful because of all of damage
you could potentially take yeah those
things are annoying very very annoying
oh there's a spider right there though
[Music]
Wow all right maybe
here we go get out of here no no I'm
gonna finish okay you really feel that
way
I'm just focused on the game yeah I got
a I he's free to say whatever he wants
to everyone but if I was in the
situation he was in
I probably wouldn't be talking very much
only because of those fireballs each hit
for like a hundred something at least so
it gets pretty sketch but he's doing a
good job descriptions only a scion of
the Imperial line may enter relatives
still qualifies
let's go deeper so we know boy oh yeah
let's go deeper did I make a mistake I
don't know find out I don't think I
think it's gonna follow they're all over
for good oh okay so he's okay where you
can fight him okay that's good
however
yeah you're good I think it'll be fun
he'll marry Oh yep very good you have to
stop time later oh I have no idea what
that does
that's yeah so if you ever need it
I think the X will stop
oh you're doing work on him though and
you saw three heels which is good
nice good very good want to be in those
class it's like wow
yeah but I'm my own man oh it's okay man
it's not so well you can always go back
to the real world man and fight some
skeletons all right you're slowly
reading I got it
yeah hopefully this is the last of him
and there's no like human version no
yeah
so that beat these guys all right all
right but you have a bunch of ulcers for
your casters nice oh nice
demon aid me
yeah well we fine you got some scorpions
got some skeletons that guy took like no
damage okay feel confident for you
always reflecting them okay that's some
next-level stuff that's actually pretty
cool I had not fought this guy before
the guy with the shield
yeah you just reflected it again the old
circle strat it's like Dark Souls great
nice let's get some good press correct
the Force has been slain by an upstarts
the people are calling the theocratic
ception forces it is only a matter of
time before the theocrats forces arrive
to sack Thal so you've been playing it
for a bit would you what do you think of
the game um I mean it's got a lot of ve
like classic kind of like like action
RPG mechanics that I like you know being
able to you you know put stats in the
way I want to you know level different
skills that I want to and then the loot
is pretty cool but it's hard to say like
I want I like what Diablo 3 did later on
it's like play-doh same with path of
Exile like the post Reaper of souls like
yeah when they really got more creative
with their like legendaries changing how
you play you know space off weapons you
use and also moving the auction I like
the auction house you can actually know
I know someone who is able to pay his
rent from cashing out but I hope that
the the loop mechanics are getting more
complex as you play more but the systems
are there and I like good action RPG
games which could lose good story
obviously a story doesn't matter as much
to me personally play it's nice to have
two why would these poultry items
warrant an honorable suicide hmm and
what is the Imperial stuff I've never
heard of any such relic we should be
using that thing alright we out of here
we out or I can just teleport all right
enough from here this is just that's
just what you're partying to feel I
think you need the like Waypoint thingy
do that which is like really close to
where you are if you switch back to the
game and I think you can just like walk
south of where you're at right now think
that by doing what you just did those
would stop but they don't I think this
woman talks too much
yeah it's by the story
all right back to now I think so yeah I
think that's so finished I'm gonna go
talk to our shot killed some spiders
gonna get some money for it or wait is
this yeah we're going up now okay and
then oh I think it's because you didn't
unlock the one in the city oh okay I
knows this guy let's see what happens
let's just you're giving him money
though yeah it's a game having how much
do I have gambling all our money away at
least this is Soho yeah maybe I should
leave are you doing anything with valve
as Ross per game so I'm not I know Ben
jank has been playing so there's our
resident World of Warcraft guy that
maybe yeah good chance I'm gonna be
checking that out did you play well oh
man did I play wow back in college yeah
I was really into the game I got in 2005
and I played it from 2005 all the way to
2010 I stopped when the Cataclysm
expansion came out okay that's a that's
a good one to stop that I think yeah I
mean add a lot of fun changes but I just
sort of fell out of the grind and I just
couldn't get into it anymore I mean some
of the newer stuff I heard is a pretty
good though so all that there's a you
know you can actually build bases now
they've had Garrison's for a little bit
I forget which expansion got introduced
with but legions which was the last one
I heard good things about Pierce people
feel the same way about um saddle for
Asura it's actually shocking if you
think about it just how long that games
went out and how it's like probably one
of the very few remaining successful
mmo's like those last time you sign a
memo it's like battle royale now yeah oh
yeah well it was MOBA then it went I'm
sure like maybe someday we'll see like a
World of Warcraft battle royale that's
to hopefully
yeah then come up with like some story
reason where you know the magic of the
world just brings all the fighters
throughout history into some spot and
they all have to fight each other you
know the interesting thing is riot
teased apparently recently like Oh what
have we made an MMO so who knows monitor
it's PC ps4 and Xbox one tabula rasa
sayang do you play path of exile if so
what's your favorite build flicker
strike is fun and funny fun and funny um
I haven't played in a long time I'll be
honest I played a lot when it first came
out and then now I watch more than I
play just because I don't know it's just
it's fun to do it's fun watching people
just get creative yeah I like watching
people race too for like hundred because
like that was the old Diablo 2 kind of
things like when ladder reset people
would race to 100 and so that spirit
lives on with path of Exile which is
awesome it's cool to see different weird
wacky things I don't know if I have a
favorite build because I mean I haven't
played in a while personally interested
ohms were opie right ok remember you
need a lot of gear to be like there's
this old build I don't know if it's
still widget now but uh it was called
Mike Tyson basically I believe that was
sort of unarmed pugilist where they
would basically dump like this like a
bunch of like gems it's like unarmed
like focusing on strength and armed
abilities and it was basically one punch
kill so one punch man yeah actually this
was before one punch man became actually
yeah recently somebody had a clip of
like Mike Tyson like back in the day
just training yeah it's just you scary
dude he's a scary man like just the
speed of his punches and the impact of
his punches is what made him so deadly
yeah well we got another quest but we
can also go to that door that was a
little walking cat is a grim Don I'm big
fan of grim Don I played a little bit of
that too and that was no that was pretty
good too but I never got into it once it
like actual proper release and I didn't
they've been updating it still so that
game was on Kickstarter as well
it was crowdfunding title and it just it
seems to really developed a really
passionate fan base funny things have
low Raza is like a long time ago like
one of the first I know maybe the first
or second path of Exile videos I ever
did on GameSpot I actually got to do
like a let's play with Chris Wilson that
was pretty cool
he just happened to be in town I was
having him teach me the ways all right
what are you up to now cuz I totally was
not paying attention well I opened the
door to the Arcanum oh nice and I'm fine
trying to find the hooded man okay so if
you do fine over here just I can't get
to him though you won't oh yeah you can
no oh by the way if you do do this fight
that's the end we could cut away and
then come back in car city Bruce Lee's
still better have you watched Bruce Lee
fight err well you can watch it man
fight Mike Tyson always like the Bruce
Lee video where he does the one-inch
punch it's a classic my name is Chris
good stuff evil-looking hooded man and I
guess it's because we're in the normal
world the most powerful institution in
the heretic kingdoms
there's no co-op and for chose to betray
and see like I'm pretty sure you played
as her at some point or something that
looked like her but I'm not a hundred
percent sure I can remedy this but you
must defend me for a moment so you got
to defend him no no she was pretty rough
oh wow wow I'm getting robbed right
gotta put her in that trap by the way so
you somehow have to lure her into those
blue traps don't then it doesn't really
matter and frontback she has a demon
form too well the good news is she might
be too strong for us anyway so can't you
can't beat her it's like a no I save ya
last name that means I can leave it's
fine yeah so you I would be at least
level four to fight her yeah let's stay
out of there she's pretty rough well we
did get another quest - yeah get his
sword right yeah yeah we'll go do that
come back to that at the end all right
how much are we good on time uh we gotta
like a good another thirty forty-five
minutes okay
another we can do another co-op quest
then we can check out what what else we
have
if not we can always just go and do that
question no you're definitely not doing
know if the heirloom is yeah right at
our recommended level turn do it more oh
yeah you finished that one - yes
well not each track so it should show up
on your map hmm
you stunned her in shadow for him yes I
believe so
so you kind of want to time it get her
to walk in one of those circles stunner
there's other moves at least when I was
playing the warrior that I couldn't push
her in these games still not dead yet no
I think they're they're still definitely
a demographic like a pretty big
demographic that played them I mean
think about path of Exile success
they've been a free-to-play game for
like a longest time just they're seeing
year-over-year success with every
expansion been it's been really amazing
to see how much that game is grown yeah
Diablo 3 another game that you know not
maybe not necessarily going as strong as
like a path of Exile but still like when
they have major updates I see people
going back to it so there's that and
I've been actually waiting for a long
time for a kind of hybrid action RPG
games from ncsoft which is lineage
eternal which looks like an MMO a RPG
like if I had to just like really
quickly describe it so that still hasn't
come out yet so like I'm like man I want
that game but sadly not so much here's
the old walk around and talk to all the
merchants in the city streets in search
of someone to buy your unwanted goods
one thing I did want to play that I
didn't get a chance to because this
whole thing was the path of Exile battle
royale but they actually trying to
pulled it off they like very like oh
that works I'm kind of shocked that it's
not in the game and that's the thing
they did it as like a goof and obviously
but it was uh they finished it they
finished making it in like a day and it
apparently took them only like 24 hours
yeah they saw a ridiculous amount of
players jumping in just so they can try
it out and you know they're also
considering whether they should make
that a real thing so this looks good for
now I can't wait for Diablo for to be a
thing yeah I'm hope
chase that this year they finally like
show something even if it's just like
Diablo with like a for like as like a
logo I'll take that because there's been
like multiple job postings I think that
like have come out now in the last year
that's like all this we need someone to
work on an action or I remember when the
original Diablo was actually announced
sorry double 3 was announced like 10
years ago actually this is really yeah
that's
do you remember that contractors is it
it can he cannot have been 10 years it's
announced and announced okay okay the
answer MIT was in 2008 gotcha
okay all right no no yeah we're not yeah
yeah I remember there's that a sort of
controversy with Diablo 3 where they
they changed the art style they made it
more dark a lot of people were upset are
you Gadwal 3 not the other way around
because well as like them truly wanted
it to be dark its to not
that's why path of exile is like deals
war I always said feels more like a
diablo 2 successor than the hablo 3 was
just because you still had the ability
to really pick and choose how you made
your character was like you know with
diablo 3 it's weird to not think or
weird to think that they didn't already
have consoles in their minds because of
just like how they limited your skill
like this goes you could actually use i
wanted a darker tone hard to show off
the other classes tabula rasa because we
don't have them and I think each
character has to use like just specific
like certain types of weapon types so
like she's gonna mainly use stabs I
think you might be able to switch your
staff I don't know
mmm-hmm yeah you have any level I can
use if she can use bows well not
actually now she ya not notable oh you
gonna use yeah that's is better right
yeah
slightly can I compare they're yours
hasn't NASA's in it though and it's on
maybe I can swap it out but that one's
saying that you're gonna get six more
damage I think is what it is you know I
don't think I can tell if there's a
cartoon compared to the Ala - yeah I
don't necessarily disagree with that at
all
yeah I want it like as many people are
in the chat saying just it's not the
Apple 3 as it stands it's not a dark
game in terms of its aesthetics +10
skill damage alright oh no turn that
blue by adding something to it
well I switched it this is the one I had
okay this one's better but I lose the
attack speed yeah it's okay no
trade-offs yeah alright yeah for the
most part oh just going back to tabula
rasa's a comment for the most part the
characters themselves are pretty like
static like a you know you get a lot of
like characters within a particular
class and that's where the sort of
variety comes from where you can easily
fill out your own party wonder once we
get deeper sure but of course the
constant is always this character who is
the devourer yeah who is always there
and you know the leader I guess you can
say why don't you do the sword quest
that I do in the talk you talk to you
because that one at least I know will
pull you into like a area where you'll
fight and stuff like
I think it's down there yep hmm all
right yeah I agree
tabla I'm just saying that it kind of
what Maksym saying to just like how
Diablos so when you're in terms of
skills and each class has a really
limited amount of builds pppoe which
type of Exile has so many possible
builds yeah I mean usually I've asked
this question too before to some of the
objects some of the Diablo devs when you
know I got lucky either Blizzcon or
they're in town for like GBC or
something I'm like well you know I play
a lot of Java 3 or I did and there is
always like one strand maybe if you're
lucky two builds per class that were
actually like legit viable in that like
you know reset or whatever
even with legendaries and all that
becoming more creative and also kanai's
cube but i would always ask like so
what's the plan to try to like make more
bill to Bible and they're like well you
know like items and things like that are
supposed to help but you know if you're
really a min maxing it's generally
you're gonna play one or two builds and
that's the one unfortunate thing whereas
some of the chat has mentioned already
that you know something like path of
Exile does offer the ability to really
play certain ways and still be viable
some are more risky than others you know
some of our bills that you would never
play in hardcore but it'd be totally
fine for softcore also I don't think you
can kill that thing so just be FYI that
little thing that you can spawn and
stuff
I'm almost called Diablo to play
Broadway so much played a lot of
pleasure out of DT way back today it's
been way too much time and then I've
only found one stone of Jordan legit
ever in my life also like my one funny
story with Diablo 2 is one of those one
of my friends who works in the office as
well the social media producer Julio
maybe I just never did an abandoned we
used to play Diablo 2 a bunch together
and we were mewling stuff like back and
forth to each other and all of a sudden
do you play a lot of Diablo - oh yeah do
you do you remember when they had the
hablo clone as like one of those things
to get people to throw away all their
like duped soj yeah so he we just like I
was like oh [ __ ] like we got the text
prompt and I was like hey switch to your
main right now diablo clones in our game
and that was like probably one of like
the coolest moments and my Diablo
like to experience was just having
diablo clones wan and killing him and
getting the little wasn't
Annihilus jam or something like that I
forget which it's like the thing that
you put in the for it had like three or
like had like multiple stats for your
character it was like really good
because it was a small charm mine
anyways
oh oh hello oh I think at the yep mhm
as I said you sadly have to kill that
guy thing you call a friend how that
works serious bringing a golem out yeah
this is how you escape getting blocked
you just path to another realm oh man
you're destroying those guys must be
high level we must be like unless those
guys must be like level 2 or something
yeah POA is not on ps4 it's on I think
just Xbox one NPM for those yeah Xbox I
think that's right I mean not a hundred
percent sure so I can't say for sure
yep cow portal for uh like quick level
of actually bail runs we're really good
for leveling up and alt used to do that
all the time then you do the just like
level characters too and hope that you
got like what was at a goal or a mal
rune from the forge I don't remember
this and I think huh oh so you can put
yourself behind the fence or behind that
bookshelf yeah yeah or although you're
not gonna be able to push it sorry
influence but that is how we're gonna
beat this puzzle okay this is how we're
gonna beat this puzzle I think you were
right yeah we get to his chest no
disrespect to looks like a Diablo copy
ah I think it's a little bit more than
that
it's Diablo s I think this story
elements are deeper and I think the
switching characters is a different
mechanic for the puzzles and things like
that also single players not co-op but I
mean a lot of the action RPGs I'm sure
that have come out have learned certain
things from each other and you know are
taking certain aspects of it and then
trying to do their own spin or twist on
it so how do I get up here so pathways
right there
the other thing I like about path is
like just like how they've come so far
in terms of like you can just like just
like list items from you know your
inventory to for trade and like people
can just tell you which number thing to
tell like they want to train with I
don't know there's a lot of cool stuff
that's happened over time will there be
a po8 version for ps4 I have no idea yet
you'd have to ask grinding Gear games or
I guess Sony would have to believe in it
to want it yes into it I guess it's the
other aspect of it this looks hard it's
not too bad there's certain there's
definitely certain situations that I
feel like are harder than others like
that like fighting a boss boss the boss
fights are definitely more intense and
then like if you're fighting stuff
that's like higher level that gets kind
of messy here definitely you got to get
to that room or up above somehow
yeah thing if you go back down just left
no the other way sorry I guess down was
the orientation based off of what I was
looking at sorry and then I think can
she open that door or did you say it was
locked I think you got the key from
beating that guy no it's not opening
what oh no that's fine um I could have
sworn that guy was supposed to give you
the key the guy that you just in up top
probably thought it sounds like it's
opening at you exit and come back in
yeah maybe let's try that the old soft
reset check out immortal unchain it's a
Dark Souls game with guns
alright I remember seeing this one yeah
that makes me kind of think of like
something like the surge but not really
yeah oh this game yeah yeah yeah well
it's gonna be a ps4 September 7th okay
keep an eye out on that cool same day as
a spider-man actually oh really okay
keep it in mind for the week then um I
feel like there's melee weapons in this
game too though yeah he's pulling a
melee right there well you can't see it
fortunate to see how that yeah let's
find the key okay so I lied then I
thought he got the key I can't remember
every question fortunately Diablo 3 is
better I'm sure in some facet it is but
it's also been out way longer
I shall handle this myself
I'm going to do a better job of looking
for this key instead of chat for now yes
what was down that way nothing oh sorry
oh that was it okay that was that
there was nothing in there because I was
just a item near something over here no
I think it's pretty straightforward so
if it's not there then it might be back
down near the gate but like maybe north
of it
Lovelace is playing at a BS streamer it
looks really cool oh nice
Oh so how do okay but we can't get up
there because it's blocking that so if
we go back that way oh we can't go to a
lot of family that's really weird yeah
take that rat yeah I don't know to be
honest that's weird yeah
because as mentioned at least from what
I remember from my playthrough is like
when I told that guy the guard like he
dropped the key maybe we can try this
and you got to take the 1256 one which
was literally just then so yeah don't
you see if that was far enough back this
one yeah we'll have to see if that was
before you went back out and back in I
don't know oh that's good it's got the
maybe and I will find out
same thing we're in the same mess yeah
interesting I guess you're just gonna
have to go and finish that other trying
to fight that boss at level 30 unless we
had another quest that we didn't do yet
the one we'll really sweet we're going
to try go back to the hostel maybe
there's something there possibly I I
think if you do all the merchants he'll
send you to the hostel okay let's do
this
so why does it just do that for now
sorry chat yeah it's a preview so you
know no I'm sure actually it brings up a
good point KP we can play mouse keyboard
you can play mouse key right so mouse
and keyboard just for you can't remember
your hotkeys
yeah I want to say the gem is s but I'm
not 100% on that so just be mindful if
you need that for some reason the finest
can you tell me the story behind this I
don't know anything about that ask
Robert the owner their parents met once
which when you play there well I
remember when we got that load like not
troll to know that we all interpret it
as like oh it's Diablo making this like
joke that it's gonna come to switch
because it was like a light switch
Diablo thing in the wall that lit up and
they tweeted that only that there's the
quest description for the key have any
hints I don't know you'd have to go back
in the journal prints match just burn
through it wasn't evening times burn
through the crazy thing is I remember
this and I was like I don't get why
they're still all lit up like I didn't
talk to them but it's just how it is
yeah I had fine Farrah's Pharaohs who's
hey rules what do you know about Fairuz
making I got it right
hey roomie does they play better with a
controller I think it's up to you but I
don't know now that's fine either way
but if he asks motions
Lisa dangerous times come several my
fine wares I have the best prices of
armor what do you know about Fairuz
making I don't really know what Pharaohs
gets up to no forget I asked
Elms mayor what do you know about the
Soraa mercenary coming to throw we can't
tell when you've beat Elms mayor
come back anytime
all right this is good it's now updated
address you can either tell me what your
deal with the surah was or you can
experience the power of a mage firsthand
job right in the streets I just arranged
the messenger I swear
Kent he paid me in silver for informing
him but I was only doing what Kent asked
of me
you have my word best weapons in there
what was Kenshin she sold him hunter the
east you wouldn't before she came to
third she is their finest handing over
the sky as a way to wipe out her - all
right the ghost of a sniper oh that's
the guy that's that little dude that you
can do anything about
well I cleared out this place for the
most part so shouldn't be not too
difficult I haven't played much pillars
of eternity have you a bit yeah okay
would you say this no nothing like my
okay again this is more in the vein of
Diablo thinking I have to go devour mode
here all right
[Applause]
so she did not betray us guarded her
fallen remains since they death how
touching
come spirit die vigil has ended
oh did you just get another oh hey this
is like uh like so this is kind of what
you meant by having like a different
type of archery class done it this way
Thanks I never got this guy so new
carrot oh you can give him the short bow
maybe yeah yeah down all the way
Oh God we were saving it for this guy we
knew all along
hashtag planned all right oh he's fancy
yeah oh look at that helm that's sick
I think the cloak never added anything
which is like weird but whatever it's
fine now boots give them a Fox ring and
another this is exactly what do you have
a neck frame maybe maybe not no and the
neck necklace sorry yeah nothing all
right well that's still pretty good we
had quite a bit of stuff around that's
all right we got two points to use so
tabula rasa you got your wish we got in
your character are we doing landline and
roll yeah or totem I know it's like a
silence so yeah you can either silence
your opponents enemies or you could do a
role it's up to you all right
you technically have his stats too if
you want to know that's right
sorry backseat gaming oh and talent
you go heavy stats are you just gonna
give them do this I like it that's what
I would've did yeah
that's you
glass cannon alright shoot now we only
have that other quest or the big quest
now I think I know what they're gonna
say what this guy just running around
sure oh okay oh you can't unless you're
okay that makes sense see I was like
there's no way they're gonna let this
guy run around
why don't you look in your journal I
think there's only those two left though
and the heirloom and the hooded man's
the problem with it okay let's see yes
what can be found somewhere in this at
the southeast use a key to enter the
cellar which we already did locate the
sword yeah so we need a way into that
locked door that we can't and like
within your quest items I think I only
saw the staff - I didn't see like the
key is like a thingy kiloton we're
playing shadows awakening action-rpg and
we're still screwed here it looks like
yeah I might have hit a bug on this one
yeah well I think you should just do the
level the the big quest at level three
let's do it and just cycle through your
characters and hope for the best unless
I Rashad somehow has another quest but
even then like it's flying we hope very
little action for an a RPG well we just
actually picked up a new hero and we got
stuck on that one question cuz I think
we're on a preview build and something
weird happened because I've definitely
passed that quest myself so we're gonna
do pretty much like that last one of the
last major quests that you can do in
this this area unless maybe we can go
off to the side and in there I don't
know if there was like a actually yeah
there was another side guys right so we
can do that before we go in to the main
area or whatever
hopefully
find something here some blues can't
wear it level five oh maybe I highly
doubt the key would be in here but one
could hope is there anything in that
thing Missy
yeah what was even the point
was there anything as a demon over there
why not right
oh that we probably can't equip I bet
you because it's little five all right
in any event here we go so yep
as mentioned that's one of the hunters
that you could pick up hopefully I have
many questions for you who did man I
expected you sooner listen all this
right let's do it show me that you can
win this place but you chose to betray
us unfortunate timing I can remedy this
but you must defend me for a moment all
right so we're trying to defend him
while trying to put him into those
circles so if you alright that's one of
four times three more times you gotta do
that this is good this is good
got her barely
Oh what you starter this is good skin
oh that's sucked she's like right on the
outskirts yep yep one more time get kite
it no come this way
yeah
oh wow okay that's that last one didn't
my gratitude but time is short it will
not be bound for long
I will implant a memory suggesting life
led towards you will forget this meeting
as soon as I release it I'm afraid
there's no way to liberate me its death
would free you but I am reluctant to
lose my only Ally I'm keen on that plan
either you can play either way people
NASA disenchantment to your mind you may
get an opportunity to sever the
connection from the inside it's actually
less than 40 on Steam right now if
you're looking for shadows 34 carefully
I cannot hold it much longer
her in an Avenger suspect they will
return to thought shortly then I must be
going this is like a Diablo like me
again well mm-hmm time to have a chat
she was a demon like myself
karissa soul has indeed been stolen by a
devourer yet you are not like that demon
it may have had one soul in its
possession I do not know what will
happen to you as you acquire more Souls
but if we are fortunate
it will only serve to grow your power
further no it's blue road sir you have
more questions
thou art pursued our escape from foe not
a problem for me far tougher for you I'm
afraid take this it will open a path
into the deeper catacombs there is a
path out of Thal that way oh wait maybe
you're not done yet you gotta use this
key our good old goes well so we gotta
go to scale and then that's where we end
the stream see I told you you didn't
take five hours you have more questions
I shall depart for the catacombs now I
will be watching the skull gate for you
if this is a trap believe me if I
intended you harm
I would scarcely have waited this long
to act don't worry about me worry about
Val Corrine and Avanza now go while you
still can
why can't we do that
one day we'll be able to teleport don't
do it
good wise wise decision playas monk I
can't I am a month meme though in Diablo
monks are fun it's dangerous to go alone
take this thank you I don't know
hopefully he gave me what I needed one
say the combat is necessarily like as
impact was the hablo 3 at least not what
the spawns I played with but I mean the
combat is similar
is when I think impactful I think like
you know dropping meteors like playing
that's a sore core you know seven aside
to strike or something like that we're
like you really feel the weightiness of
that move but yep we're gonna have to
clear a bunch of stuff every night I
don't exactly remember
oh we were in here earlier huh that's
our old friend
[Applause]
all right we gotta escape stole the
other catechins which we're attempting
to do
let's see if Alessandro can escape in 13
all right let's do it
unless level for to be nice yeah it's a
combustible spider anyway to me just so
you know to like every now and then
you'll run into like a shadowy guy that
sells like the shark or like you know
let you replenish the soul shards for a
cost which is nice
oh yeah there's like one more boss I
think before you actually get out of the
city
let's see if we get there the crits are
real
so this is where like you know you can
switch through your cycle through your
characters definitely cycle through
skills and abilities not wonderful that
is actually only triggered by you attack
or not
what the hell maybe blue wrote sir
oh wow so you're able to use his ability
with your character so changing
abilities oh this one hmm wait not there
yet there's a boulder there's gonna be a
boulder puzzle that I was mentioning
from earlier that I was not super fond
of level 4
so how are you liking that this guy
sorry
feel like he needs a little more moves
I'd be like maybe I picked the wrong
ones like where they're sort of
situational about you yeah oh oh I see
what you're saying okay oh it's not even
this one that's the where am i moving
this okay over there yeah and I did not
have double range when I was playing or
any seems like a lot easier there
glassier for sure but here we go just
roll in a boulder
okay you can scale up to it if you want
and you go for but to you
by the way if you guys didn't know we're
always live but well not always on on
the weekdays we're live at 11:00 a.m.
with GameSpot daily and 11:30 with
GameSpot live what you're watching right
now so if you haven't subbed hit that
fall button [ __ ] so that you get
informed as to when we go live play a
wide variety of games from previews of
games when we have early builds as in
today to you know games that might have
weekly challenges you know like
fortnight all the way to sometimes
having kind of like mini shows in a way
Thursday's great hopper day with Mike
and Rob which they pretty much add
permadeath to all the games that they're
playing and when they die in one they
move on to the next and then Fridays
eventually will be a more community
driven stream with Ben and Don Luke so
look forward to those
I think good yep thanks should stream
some chasm tomorrow funny I think we are
so taking tomorrow I'm gonna have a
chasm shroom where it's gonna have a
guest in but yeah come back at 11:30
tomorrow because we'll be doing that I
think it launches tomorrow right
I hope lost art gets localizer it when
eternal in it I think its lineage
eternal but yeah I really want that one
I'll read cooky see I've been waiting
for a while and I just haven't seen oh
that's the guy has let you recharge
which is pretty nice recharges here our
soul stones so that our soul shards so
that you can like heal again because I
think there's like a boss by rote
soonish and I had to use that a couple
times I think he sells yeah just for him
yep
now it's already dead how do I get them
here oh I see yeah here you go here's a
fun puzzle for ya you're probably gonna
beat it real fast
I'm gonna be sad not really WTF happened
to call of duty what is this first 90
minutes our shadow is awakening gameplay
which is specifically in the title don't
know why there was some word that there
would be all the duty just okay we do
call of duty that would be on Friday I
believe that's when the multiplayer beta
will be available for tonight greater
than cod to cyber tiger I mean we'll
have to see because I feel like
I want to see what black out how black
out feels to be honest that beta is
coming in September by the way looking
forward to it just curious I mean
hopefully it's good you know these both
are all woes I know all about them
also if you want a pro tip technically I
think you can do it the way you are but
another way that could help and I'll
tell you now is you can switch to inform
and then it's it's it basically freezes
time but I wanted you to struggle a
little bit like I did just so you could
feel the same anger that I went through
and the funny thing is you're not even
doing the yeah okay there's this one I
think no you had the right one I think
it just happened that you couldn't pull
that well because you know the laughing
yeah unless it's the first one
it's the first one the first in the last
no yeah see you needed that last one you
almost
oh right nailed it all right yes feels
good all right mini-boss it is I can't
remember guys yep
solid move good plating is there's an
actual like reject thing in here and you
could sit in that now you can't cast
spells not sure that spider would but my
cyber shocker I've sort of started to
lean that way personally I don't know
why maybe because it's sometimes it's
like games that like I had mentioned
like not really playing path of Exile as
much anymore but I watch a lot I don't
know to me it's just easier that way I
guess I can kind of just like relaxed
you know eat something or whatever
watching streaming all right we're doing
well here
there's that's not the boss boss though
I think there's still one left
great it's a it'll be a doozy he could
heal up though or be areas
ps4 PC and Xbox one Santiago
she looks like the diablo 2 amazon i
don't know about that she's oh this is
the boss i think that's how you get past
the that one area there's sister yeah i
don't think you can get in there until
you keep that guy and i think there
might be more than just him I think
there's three of those areas oh that
sucks to you the fire yeah I think
there's one of those bosses at the end
of this room too
barbecue
yes Nova
we're currently using a gamepad on PC
you got to do this at like each both
sides I think to actually along this
will be fun for you yep that's what I
would've did casual loot while fighting
semi boss like this any upgrade here
londo doing the right thing he's making
it his life easier by clearing the ends
you're tickling that Archer
Oh interesting so you get silence does a
human get hit by those pathetic you get
hit as a demon you're stunned
hmm immune to lightning direct
resistance thank you well guys haven't
slowly but surely
the game will release August 31st on PC
and then I think early September on
consoles what I saw
against wow this looks cool are you
liking it so far yeah I think it's
interesting I'd like to get a little bit
farther into it it's just to have a
better understanding of what it looks
like to have you know a full party more
skills maybe some some higher and boots
just to see you know how much that makes
a difference because you you want that
depth or that you know where all those
layers of combat and all that stuff and
stats all right some goodies
so now fun facts you have to do that in
the other side now you meant to [ __ ]
yourself can I go back to the show yes
you can
I think it costs a little bit more
silver to get them back but it's totally
worth it
and plus and we're ending the stream
here so my yep there's no reason not to
to press on
thanks for stopping by side
before a princess up there girl I don't
think that's necessarily fair Cory I
wouldn't say that it's just a Diablo 3 :
I think it has its own things that it's
trying to accomplish so I mean it just
sounds more like to me that you're
wanting to I'll go through to be good
and you just don't like Diablo 3 and
also this is a this game is actually a
part of a series so there's been other
entries in this sequel yeah this is the
technically the third game there was the
cult heretic kingdoms in late 90s then
shadows heretic kingdoms in 2014 and of
course now we have shadows awakening so
this has been in the game for a while
everything mr. Nevada please be mindful
of what you saying I don't want to have
the time Yahoo just trying to be silly
KP says the movement seems to be a
little easier with compared with the
controller compared to key where Mouse I
think it's preference I think you're
used to playing an air PG with the mouse
keyboard I think it's about the same
it's not like the hablo where when he
went to console it actually had a role
that the keyboard mouse version plus
they had a redesign a lot of yeah like
they certain nuances of the game play to
fit that cut the controller yeah
oh wow surprise that let you heal
through the kind of like stung
essentially
stood like taking it you know you know
slow and steady you know when's the race
all right we had a [ __ ] there that was
good
I want heretic kingdoms on January 3rd
2015 unless I offered this as a garnish
yeah as I mentioned it's a sequel to
that so it makes sense that you have
access to that since you have the like
at least to the access to the demo plate
the previous versions
what's up masher
right and I think the doorway should be
open now
let's search for next okay
love that move very good
yes the adventures of Van Helsing that
was a was a one from a while ago too
I played very a little bit and I kind of
was in the same way as we AWS I don't
think it was the game was around for
they made like three different oh yeah
cause like one was like a tower defense
game wasn't it I remember that okay
another Waypoint maybe not
Oh an activation case by the level of
procedurally generated I don't think so
- I think these since it's a
single-player I think they're kind of
reset
but again haven't gotten that far into
it personally
for both of us I think we're both like
all signed reply as like an hour - and I
have like three plus three - four
all right I think I honestly like turned
down three of the levers at some point
and then like I just yellow and I took
the damage I think and healed myself
because I was like I'm not gonna try to
figure this out I'm sure there is a
pattern there you go
and there's a will there's a way ladies
and gentlemen oh look there's two of
those guys now should be fun
oh and the reflect guys this gon be gage
who the double silence Rousey's
take the high ground you could that's
fair Bob I'm pretty sure they'll still
chase us though
I thought she was insane my life for
iron
jk jk
whittling them down while these Lee Chi
hoon
almost almost I just had this bad
feeling they're gonna get really
summoned at some point yup like that
instantly Rhys um and yeah I was at
least one of the summer guys is almost
dead
interesting the last heal didn't
actually do anything oh I am an ER oh
god okay you can choose which one
all right we got you go along to some
aggro
all right one down one to go
almost there those two guys clearly poor
AI and won't come to the corner so who's
excited for RDR to Red Dead Redemption
to you I think a lot of people are
[Music]
okay you might be able to do that oh no
you go up from K oh you got one hour
puzzle actually hey that rule does
actually
yeah blows air therefore there's more
fear factor compared to Diablo oh this
is a good one
so you just not the so switch forms and
you'll see something yeah if you need to
here it is that but I think to get
through this you have to like actually
walk on those steps correctly or the
fire comes on you know what maybe this
is the right time for a keyboard and
mouse so you want a more precise
movement yes
[Music]
I think you got to do it as anymore I
see okay so you have to remember I real
talk because I kept failing this cuz I
couldn't remember name you you can't
pass the puzzle that way ah so you have
to do it properly but like I said if you
have to you can regen at that little
spot over there it's time they forgot so
I literally took out a piece of paper
and drew how to get there because I
couldn't remember exactly an arrow would
always miss a square or something okay
alright so if you need me to do that I
can but you think you're fine now your
fire
and then you have to do it within the
time of the thing out like right after
you oh crap the golems gonna break it DJ
May it's gonna come out PC ps4 Xbox one
just be mindful before you walk because
I feel like your lover times gonna run
out oh you know what it is is you might
be stepping on the wrong stone which is
what's triggering the fire so are like
as you're walking nope
all right but I'm still gonna draw it
because I don't want to be stuck here
for that long not gonna be stuck here
trust me man
okay what others have begun Avia shall
finish
must I do everything myself
I didn't get to finish strong so I don't
know got it okay
do you want to know yes so tell go one
the to that one and then down one and
then across and up ah there you go
you got had I did I give it to you now
you should be good it doesn't matter all
right
nailed it it's attack you think it's
simple because you think you see it
right but then as you get through it
because part of it's like you're focused
on not stepping on the wrong thing you
actually start to forget and so my
advice is just draw it because I I had
to draw it out and maybe that's just me
maybe I struggled with it more than some
other people would but I definitely drew
it out because I couldn't remember it
and I'll just be honest about it it's
fine think that should let us out
what's up P bode on TV show are you oh
this might that's it I don't remember
this is the boss yeah this is the boss
he did except you had way more yeah yeah
oh yeah I have no more healing right
nope
you shall not leave by this pass so show
you like I would say this is like almost
like the chapter boss guy before you get
into the next chapter this is where the
last bite we can pretty much show you
guys but
could be interesting
yeah
this is where I think most people are it
actually is easier to like get on with
ah yeah from downtown
oh wow every one of those oh man this is
so much easier for you than it was for
me because I had no rich carrot juice
nice that instance
and he has summoned
boy some pretty epic if all us honor to
do this with three characters no heels
right jinxing him by saying that
commentators curse founder of
commentators goes Oh phase two P to the
quarry is the golem
yeah give my friend Oh bullet-hell still
exist though
got more summons which is super annoying
yeah so this boss wives grateful
got a lot going on law stuff you don't
just stand in one spot obviously you
gotta watch out for that you can't
actually hurt him that way I don't think
sadly
Oh
this is that's awkward
[Music]
[Music]
let's say you chat
[Music]
Oh boxed-in still alive oh no I guess
although oh wait because you have the
archer guy still that's why you can't do
any damage to these got that Gollum
alright one life one opportunity mom's
sphaghetti not bad considering no heels
I feel like you would have easily done
it with you so it's up to you you can
see if the last save is there if you
want to kill it if you want to go out
that's fine too it basically if you beat
that boss you might run back to that guy
dude I think you can't right I think so
I think you can I just forget exactly
where it is I think it's it's the next
room down right yeah yeah it's fine
I'll give them a run back so what's
unique about this game from other our a
RPGs I think it's a it's got
combinations of you know other stuff but
I mean like you can switch characters
like you can in trying solve puzzles
that way as well I think it's more like
a culmination of like a lot of nah he
doesn't need more levels I think he
literally just needs healing items cuz
he had the boss in a Phase two and
probably could I did Phase three if you
could've healed once or twice and we had
no heals at all excuse me
yeah I don't I don't think you need
anything necessarily I think if you play
the same way you did and it had six
stones to heal yourself you wouldn't
find
yeah jabs yeah I would say this is
closer to Diablo 3 than pillars
mechanically rip could try things was
thank you what others have begun a via
shall finish alright try the run back
smart play here PC PC gamer here it
saves all right let's do it
skip you can't now you I like the
attempts I don't know if they did or not
No
figured actually yeah I was gonna say I
think this worked out for you better to
feel like you're getting more shots off
and they were doing more damage
if I has like resist to magic or
something which makes sense it's like a
essentially a sorcerer himself
[Music]
see how the threes at you know sadly
Oh oh it's locked on that spike I was
like yeah big plays baby
cuckoo I thought you got by all weird
near perfect Dodge
all right back into Phase two gotta
fight a golem call them
all of it took all of it Thank You
Gollum
whatever floats your boat
[Music]
[Music]
who narrowly escaped he's too big just
ate all the hot wings
Gogol I'm soaking it all up
that's somehow still targeted the dead
golems body oh wow he crit you
p3
no I actually don't recall too much
personally this part of the fight
because if you get bottom and demon hook
oh but the bow hurts I'm so bad we
should have hey it's out cyborg got him
yeah this boss size was pretty good
though and then now we get iron the iron
guy that's the stink-sons line man all
right
I mean technically you can show them
used to use him to break down to the
thing if you want to show that real
quick what that's more or less or we
have to stop here in a second right
because yeah once you get through that
doorway it's like a it's the next area
essentially there's a shadow trader here
too
Goodwyn yeah it's a good one such an
awesome boss as cyber shockers yeah I
mean the mechanic wise it's it's good to
see that you have to do a bunch of stuff
so yeah you have to turn into this
building later you know this doesn't
matter I still got a finalist I know all
right okay geometry this is all right
but anyways thanks Alessandra for
playing that was valiant effort we got
through everything pretty much that we
could show so check that out it's coming
August 31st on PC i think it's on sale
15% off right now shadows awaken and it
should be also coming to ps4 and Xbox
one according to Amazon it's a September
4th for ps4 but take Amazon's date with
a grain of salt perhaps because I don't
know if that's for sure but what are
your last thoughts I guess after playing
you know more of it now we're looking
forward to it
what do you think about action RPGs I
guess yeah I'm a big admirer of like the
Diablo style loot action RPG games like
Diablo 3 obviously but also path of
Exile and Grim Dawn but I really dig
that this game gives you a lot of
characters to try out and yeah obviously
we've only scratched the surface here
but I'm looking forward to seeing what
else like you can find yeah same for me
I think it's just like how much more
complex does it get you know cuz doing
something like what you did there
against that boss part one of the harder
mechanics or things that we've had done
do so far as of this stream I just don't
want it to be more of that necessarily
just through the whole game but you know
it's hard to say we're early it's like
the first 90 or so minutes a little bit
more probably but maybe two hours close
to two hours now but yeah check that out
if you want to when it comes out
otherwise stay tuned a game spot for
more coverage of Shadows awakening other
air action RPG games as well hit that
subscribe button if you haven't already
it's
that you can become made aware when we
go live and also like when we do cool
features reviews previews things like
that but thanks again Alessandra for
playing thank you guys all for tuning in
and we'll see you guys tomorrow peace
bye